Britain has fallen and their economy is
in Ruins
the cost of living is now so high that
people are resorting to stealing food to
survive energy bills are rising so
quickly that churches and libraries are
opening the doors to people who can't
afford to heat their homes hundreds of
thousands of industrial workers and
University staff are going on strike and
to top it all off they can now be facing
blackouts on really cold winter nights
just when people need heating the most
but the worst part is that everything
that's happening in Britain right now is
a forewarning a preview of what's to
come in America except in America it
would be a much much larger scale
because everything that Britain has been
going through America is going through
the exact same thing right now as we
speak but to understand why we need to
take a closer look at how the British
Crisis began in the first place and it
all started with Boris Johnson stepping
down
this video was inspired by clear value
taxes videos on the subject I really
like his videos and I'll link to his
channel below if you want to subscribe
and really fast if you want to earn some
free cash then you gotta check out free
cash.com free cash.com lets you easily
earn free cash by completing simple
tasks like downloading apps playing
games taking surveys watching videos and
more a lot of websites like this are
very sketchy but free cash.com has over
20 000 positive reviews on trustpilot
and on average free cash users cash off
fifty thousand dollars every single day
from completing tests take this task for
example where you literally just have to
download The Epic Times newspaper app on
Android or this one where you just have
to sign up for Sirius xm's three month
trial for one dollar and you'll earn
9.34 cents in return once you complete a
task you'll get the reward credited to
your accounts and then you can withdraw
the money using 20 different Cash Out
options like PayPal after completing a
few offers I was able to withdraw five
dollars to my PayPal minus a five
percent PayPal fee so if you want to
start earning some free cash right now
pause the video and send it for free by
clicking my referral link below pause
the video and click the link below now
thanks to free cash for sponsoring this
video
foreign
2022 British prime minister Boris
Johnson resigned over the three years he
was prime minister he was involved in a
whole lot of scandals like throwing
parties in the middle of coveted
lockouts or appointing a guy accused of
sexual misconduct to Parliament but the
main reason Johnson was forced to resign
was the absolute chaos of the British
economy by July 2022 inflation was at
10.1 percent higher than it had been in
the past 40 years the pound was at an
all-time low against the dollar which
meant Imports were getting more
expensive GDP has been declining
basically his political career was in
the drain and everyone thought he wasn't
the right guy to dig Britain out of the
hole it was in so after more than 59
senior government officials quit because
they didn't have faith in his leadership
anymore Boris Johnson made the decision
to call it quits and hand off the mess
to someone else
that Boris Johnson is likely to Tender
his resignation by the end of this day
breaking news overnight brings prime
minister Boris Johnson has resigned now
to breaking news embattled UK prime
minister Boris Johnson is stepping down
and that's where Liz trust came in the
woman who said that she would come in
and save the day that she would
single-handedly turn the economy around
that she would cut inflation in half
lower taxes and return Britain to its
Glory Days my tax cuts will decrease
inflation but unfortunately for Liz
despite her best efforts things were
about to go from bad to much worse
Liz truss based her entire campaign to
become Prime Minister of Britain on two
things
major tax cuts in fact tax cuts so big
that the director of The Institute for
fiscal studies said that quote it's half
a century since we've seen tax cuts
announced on this scale end quote
and on top of the tax cuts she would put
a cap on energy bills according to her
these two moves would lower inflation
and turn the economy around for good
there was just one small problem thanks
to the war in Ukraine stuff like Fuel
and food aren't as easy to supply as
usual so Britain was already struggling
with too little Supply to meet demand
but what did Liz trust want to do cut
taxes and cap energy bills which would
to more money floating around for people
to spend which creates more demand
around an already dwindling supply of
stuff which would lead to more inflation
so her plan to lower inflation was
probably gonna do the exact opposite but
that wasn't the only problem see her two
little anti-inflation strategies were
going to cost the British government
more than 150 billion dollars but when
they announced these plans to the world
they conveniently forgot to include how
they planned on paying for all of them
which only meant two things borrow and
print the UK government was gonna have
to borrow and print more than 150
billion dollars in the middle of an
economic crisis and skyrocketing
inflation the market was not a fan of
this plan but despite the critics
despite all the hate Liz trust stuck to
her guns and pushed forward
I'm not going to cut the additional rate
of tax today Mr Speaker I'm going to
abolish it all together are you
absolutely committed to abolishing the
45 Pence tax rate for the wealthiest
people in the country yes
we're hearing that Liz truss is
preparing to scrap plans to remove the
45p top rate of income tax for the
highest Earnest less than 24 hours ago
the Prime Minister told the BBC she was
absolutely committed to that policy less
than 24 hours ago you were tweeting that
it was a great thing what changed we
just talked to people we listened to
people I get it and we felt that the 45p
issue the 45p rate was drowning out a
strong package of intervention on energy
a strong package of intervention on tax
cuts for people generally do you owe
people in apology we're not going to
proceed with the abolition of the rate
we've listened to people and yeah there
is humility and Contrition in that sad
the market didn't share her optimism
[Music]
September 26 2022 just 18 days after Liz
trust became prime minister the pound
nose dived against the dollar without a
solid plan to pay for all her tax cuts
investors assume the bank of England
Britain's Central Bank would either have
to print or borrow all the billions it
needed which would definitely increase
inflation and push the economy into an
even deeper crisis so instead of going
down with Britain investors got out
while they still could and sold all
their British Investments and surprise
surprise with thousands of investors
selling billions of pounds worth of
Investments the value of the pound
continued to plummet by September 28th
the pound was weaker against the dollar
than it had ever been before we're
talking about a currency devaluation of
historic proportions suddenly all those
institutions that were still in invested
in Britain saw a massive percentage of
their money wiped out and the group that
was hit the hardest British Pension
funds see Pension funds were loaded up
on a ton of British government bonds
think of bonds as simply loans to the
British government and they would use
these bonds as collateral to take out
loans from Banks and then use that new
money they just borrowed to invest in
more Investments on a much bigger scale
so when the pound tanked the bank
suddenly wanted a whole lot more money
is collateral for the loans they had
given to Pension funds and since most
pension funds's own money is tied up in
government bonds the funds had to start
selling these bonds to free up cash the
only problem was dozens of massive
Pension funds were doing this at the
exact same time so British bonds started
crashing as well the problem with
British bonds crashing is that more than
half of all of Britain's savings are
tied up in government bonds which meant
that Britain's savings were disappearing
and there was no end in sight
if someone didn't step in to stop the
bond market from crashing more than half
of all of Britain's savings would be
destroyed people's retirement would be
wiped out and Britain would be looking
down the barrel of a full-on financial
doomsday scenario and that's when the
bank of England came in just hours
before the Pension funds were about to
collapse Britain's Central Bank
announced a plan to buy up more than 65
billion dollars worth of government
bonds by creating this artificial demand
they hoped it could stop bond prices
from falling further and where would it
get that 65 billion dollars needed to
buy all those government bonds the money
printer obviously the bank of England
was going to print an unlimited amount
of money to buy an unlimited amount of
bonds the bank of England literally
announced that it would buy government
bonds quote on whatever scale is
necessary end quote and sure that would
stop bond prices from falling but more
money printing meant more inflation ah
yes what started out as an effort to
reduce inflation ended with the money
printer getting turned back on by
October 3rd Liz truss's Finance Minister
finally came out and announced that they
would be putting the brakes on their tax
cut plan to try to reverse the Meltdown
basically admitting that their original
plan was a massive failure but it was
too little too late on October 20th Liz
truss resigned as Prime Minister of
England she had been in office less than
50 days making her the shortest serving
prime minister in British history she
was eventually replaced by Boris
Johnson's former finance minister urashi
sunak but the damage was already done
right now inflation in Britain is even
higher than before at 11.1 percent the
British economy is shrinking and the
bank of England just announced Britain
is facing its longest recession yet with
2023 looking very grim
[Music]
UK government put themselves in an
impossible position they let the money
printer loose during covet by doing two
things lowering interest rates to near
zero to encourage everyone to borrow
money and by literally just printing
more money with a few clicks on a
computer screen this combo of lowering
rates and printing money is called
quantitative easing which increases the
money supply which led to insane
inflation once they saw that inflation
was very real and very much here to stay
they were like oh bloody hell we have to
reduce inflation now so they stopped
quantitative easing and started
quantitative tightening where they would
do the exact opposite they started
sucking money out of the system instead
of printing it and they raise interest
rates to discourage people from
borrowing money all of which had the
effect of reducing the amount of money
in circulation and therefore reducing
inflation the problem with this is that
every great when the money printer is on
the stock market magically skyrockets
real estate prices magically Skyrocket
and everyone feels richer and starts
overextending themselves businesses
borrow more money than they can handle
businesses start hiring employees they
don't need people Finance cars and homes
they can't afford which is all fine and
dandy when everything's going up in
price but the second the money printer
goes in reverse things start to get real
painful real fast that was the situation
Britain found themselves in they had to
reverse the money printer to reduce
inflation but reversing the money
printer was painful and it all
culminated in the Pension funds and bond
market collapsing right before the eyes
of the Central Bank and it was in this
moment that the bank of England was
faced with a choice let it all collapse
wipe out people's retirements and
savings and plunge the country into a
depression right in the middle of winter
that would lead to breadlines social
unrest and the masses coming for your
neck or you could simply turn them money
printer back on just one last time
letting it all burned down leads to a
lot of pain now suffering now while the
second option lets you kick the can down
the road just a little bit longer with
the price being inflation spiraling into
hyperinflation if you were in the shoes
of one of these Central planners which
option would you choose you would turn
the money printer back on as fast as
possible to avoid total Mayhem it was
the definition of being between a rock
and a hard place and the bank of England
caved and the next country to Cave will
be America
[Music]
was at the precipice of all this money
printing during covid printing around 30
percent of all US dollars in existence
in the span of 24 months while the U.S
treasury borrowed trillions more on top
of all that money printing to keep
sending out stimulus checks it was
absolute insanity but somehow daddy
Powell assured us plebs that resulting
inflation was just transitored by March
2022 inflation reached 8.5 percent so
just like the UK daddy Powell had to
finally accept the reality that that
inflation was not transitory that
printing 30 percent of US dollars in two
years does in fact lead to inflation so
in March 2022 the FED announced a total
180. it was going to put the money
printer in Reverse with some painful
quantitative tightening it started
sucking money out of the system
fed started with raising interest rates
by 0.25 percent almost every month but
even that wasn't enough so in June they
switched gears and started increasing
interest rates by 0.75 percent instead
the problem with this tightening is that
it's painful as soon as the FED turned
the money printer in Reverse everything
started crashing the stock market has
been going down
estate is finally starting to crack
American Savings are quickly running out
while credit card debt soars
and now we're in the same position
Britain was in right before their
Pension funds and debt Market was
collapsing and when something like that
breaks in America whether it's Pension
funds or bonds or whatever when
something like that breaks in America
America's money printer will be facing
the same dilemma as Britain's money
printer did to print or not to print if
they don't print and let the economy
correct itself we may fall into a Great
Depression unlike anything America has
ever seen before we're talking Mass
Financial suffering people being voted
out of power the poorest of the poor
will go hungry and ultimately there will
be widespread civil unrest with the
masses wanting the heads of those in
power on a stick that's option one
option two is to turn the money printer
back on Kick the Can down the road one
more time the markets will start
rallying again but inflation will will
go from around eight percent where it's
at right now to something much much
higher
if you were in Daddy Powell's shoes
which route would you take all we can
say is you better start preparing now
before it's too late subscribe to find
out what happens next
were you surprised at these Rock
personally and nuts what's up
what's up on YouTube for documentaries
on money power war and crime where we
teach you how the world really works so
you don't become a victim to it so if
you enjoyed this video click that
subscribe button below you can follow me
on Instagram jakecham but that is going
to wrap it up thanks for being part of
the watch the end Club stay dangerous
out there and I will see you guys on the
next one
foreign